Bentornato a Quantum Computing in Practice. Sono la tua conduttrice Olivia Lanes. L'ultima volta abbiamo esaminato un esempio di
un approccio di quantum computing a un problema di ottimizzazione noto come Max Cut usando la formulazione QUBO. Siamo andati
abbastanza in profondità, ma quello era solo un esempio di un approccio. Oggi discuteremo le applicazioni near-term
in modo più ampio e svilupperemo la nostra intuizione per diversi tipi di problemi per cui ci aspettiamo di trovare soluzioni quantistiche utili
e vedremo alcuni esempi recenti di lavori importanti nella nostra comunità a scala
utility. In precedenza abbiamo brevemente discusso che non tutti i problemi hanno bisogno di potere computazionale aggiuntivo,
specificamente quantum computing, per essere risolti in modo efficiente. Questi sono i problemi con cui hai già più
familiarità: aritmetica, scorrimento dei social media, forse giocare a Tetris, Doom o altri videogiochi. Consideriamo questi
problemi facili. D'altra parte, ci sono problemi molto difficili, come trovare i fattori primi di enormi
interi, e questa è la base della crittografia RSA ed è quello per cui l'algoritmo di Shor è stato effettivamente progettato per risolvere. Un altro
esempio è trovare una soluzione in un set di dati non ordinato; questo può essere teoricamente risolto dall'algoritmo quantistico noto
come algoritmo di Grover. Tuttavia, la maggior parte degli esperti concorda sul fatto che questi tipi di algoritmi richiedono
l'implementazione della correzione degli errori e non siamo ancora lì tecnologicamente. Quindi, andando avanti in questa
lezione e nel tuo percorso educativo quantistico, ricorda che stiamo cercando questo punto dolce da qualche parte qui nel mezzo.
È un problema difficile da risolvere, ma è anche quello che lo rende così divertente. Una cosa che non abbiamo ancora discusso
molto è la teoria della complessità computazionale. Uno dei motivi è che può essere un po' intimidatorio e sì,
complessa! La teoria della complessità computazionale è il campo dell'informatica che mira a classificare i problemi computazionali
in base alla loro difficoltà. Ci sono tantissime classi di complessità diverse nel computing classico, ma le più
fondamentali sono queste: i problemi P. Questi erano problemi che possono essere risolti in tempo polinomiale al variare della scala del
problema, il che significa che sono facili da risolvere. Il prossimo tipo di problema più difficile sono i problemi NP, che
stanno per non deterministico polinomiale. Questi sono problemi le cui risposte possono essere verificate in tempo polinomiale ma non
necessariamente risolte. Poi c'è NP-completo e ora stiamo entrando nei problemi davvero difficili senza
soluzioni polinomiali note. È qui che vivono problemi famosi come il problema del commesso viaggiatore e anche il gioco
del Sudoku. Ora, quando il quantum computing è arrivato, almeno in teoria, le persone hanno dedicato notevoli sforzi a cercare di
capire quale classe di problemi questi nuovi tipi di computer avrebbero potuto risolvere in modo efficiente. Una nuova classe di
problemi è stata inventata, chiamata Bounded Error Quantum Polynomial problems o BQP in breve. La loro definizione rigorosa è un po'
lunga ma è la classe dei problemi di decisione risolvibili da un computer quantistico in tempo polinomiale con una piccola
probabilità di errore. C'è una probabilità di errore perché la misurazione quantistica è intrinsecamente casuale, ma la
probabilità di errore può essere arbitrariamente piccola. Ora, tutte queste classi vivono in una classe più ampia che chiamiamo PSPACE e questo è dove
pensiamo viva BQP rispetto a tutti gli altri tipi di problemi, ma è molto difficile dimostrarlo definitivamente
matematicamente. Noterai che i problemi quantistici BQP non si sovrappongono necessariamente con i problemi NP-completi.
Tuttavia, potresti aver ancora visto alcuni approcci di quantum computing che mirano a risolvere problemi NP-completi. Perché
accadrebbe? Un equivoco comune è che non ha senso esplorare soluzioni
a problemi come il problema del commesso viaggiatore e altri problemi NP-completi per un computer quantistico o qualsiasi problema per il quale non è stata trovata
una prova matematica di un vantaggio quantistico. Tuttavia, questo non deve necessariamente essere il caso.
Trovare una prova matematica che un algoritmo quantistico sia più veloce del suo controparte classica è raro. Shor e
Grover sono solo due degli esempi di questa manciata in cui questo è stato fatto finora, ma va bene. Anzi,
gli informatici non sono ancora riusciti a dimostrare che le classi P e NP siano diverse, anche se tutta l'intuizione
ci dice che devono esserlo. Anche confrontare due algoritmi e come scalano spesso guarda al caso peggiore
per ciascuno. È abbastanza possibile che in pratica il caso peggiore non sia quello che troviamo nella vita reale. Quindi
non disperiamo; introduciamo invece l'idea di soluzioni euristiche. Se sei un
sperimentatore, conosci già e ami questi tipi di soluzioni. Un'euristica è qualsiasi approccio alla risoluzione di un
problema che sia pragmatico ma non necessariamente ottimale. Ed è fantastico perché le soluzioni non devono necessariamente
essere ottimali per essere molto utili. Ad esempio, pensa a un'applicazione finanziaria. Non abbiamo ancora trovato
un'accelerazione esponenziale per la maggior parte degli algoritmi finanziari per cui il quantistico potrebbe essere usato, ma questo non importa necessariamente. Non abbiamo bisogno di una soluzione ottimale
in finanza almeno, perché una soluzione anche solo l'1% più efficiente potrebbe equivalere a miliardi di dollari
di profitto. Quindi, come facciamo a sapere quali casi d'uso e problemi potrebbero essere adatti al quantum computing in questo momento? Con questo intendo
che c'è un motivo significativo per credere che l'utilità quantistica o addirittura il vantaggio potrebbe essere trovato ora o
in un futuro relativamente prossimo. Forse è più facile nominare prima le cose che il problema non dovrebbe certamente avere. Non
può richiedere un enorme numero di qubit. Non abbiamo ancora processori con migliaia di milioni di qubit disponibili, ed è uno dei motivi principali
per cui l'algoritmo di Shor e simili sono ancora così lontani. I circuit non possono nemmeno essere incredibilmente profondi. È davvero difficile per me
dirti esattamente quale profondità del circuit non funzionerà perché dipende da così tanti fattori, ma in generale se il tuo
esperimento richiede una profondità che non hai ancora visto raggiunta nella letteratura, potresti avere un momento difficile. E
infine, qualsiasi tipo di algoritmo che sappiamo richiedere la correzione degli errori non può essere fatto ancora. Tuttavia, quello che dovremmo cercare sono esperimenti che facciano
uso della maggior parte dei qubit disponibili su qualsiasi QPU. Abbiamo anche enfatizzato l'
importanza della mitigazione e soppressione degli errori, e infine dovrebbe esserci un'ovvia estensione ad applicazioni
future che sarebbero importanti per la società e che potremmo vedere alla fine portare al vantaggio
quantistico. Ora parliamo di alcuni esempi di casi d'uso che rientrano in tre categorie principali che abbiamo
identificato come più probabili a vedere risultati favorevoli nel breve-medio
termine. La prima area è la simulazione della natura. Ne abbiamo già parlato. Ci sono
così tante opportunità per i computer quantistici di migliorare la ricerca che viene fatta a livello molecolare e atomico
WEBVTT
e il motivo è che i metodi classici attuali sono limitati da descrizioni matematiche fondamentalmente inefficienti
delle strutture atomiche. Memorizzare e manipolare uno stato quantistico richiede una quantità esponenziale di risorse
su un computer classico, ma può essere fatto in modo efficiente su un computer quantistico, e questo è ciò che rende la simulazione di materiali
e la modellazione chimica alcune delle aree applicative più promettenti. Più specificamente, questo potrebbe portare a
sviluppi nel sequestro dell'anidride carbonica, nelle batterie alternative o nell'invenzione di nuovi farmaci. Alcuni
algoritmi particolarmente rilevanti in quest'area sono il variational quantum eigensolver VQE, che viene usato per
stimare certe proprietà di un materiale come gli stati di equilibrio o di energia minima. Un altro esempio è la
simulazione dinamica temporale TDS, quell'algoritmo viene usato per stimare funzioni di risposta o proprietà spettrali di
materiali. E volevo anche menzionare una new entry, la sample-based quantum diagonalization, di cui pensiamo sentiremo
parlare molto di più nel prossimo futuro. La prossima area applicativa è l'ottimizzazione. L'ottimizzazione è abbastanza
onnipresente nel computing come puoi immaginare, quindi i casi d'uso sono abbastanza numerosi e vari.
Tuttavia, alcuni esempi di cui si parla molto sono l'ottimizzazione del portafoglio in finanza, il design industriale e anche
la distribuzione e la supply chain. L'algoritmo più comune che probabilmente sentirai correlato all'ottimizzazione è quello che abbiamo già
approfondito, il quantum approximate optimization algorithm o
QAOA. Infine, un'area che ha suscitato molto entusiasmo negli ultimi anni è il quantum machine learning. Ora
credo sia giusto dire che sembra che il QML non avverrà presto come la simulazione molto probabilmente, ma tuttavia ci sono
alcuni algoritmi impressionanti su cui le persone stanno lavorando costantemente corrispondenti ad alcuni casi d'uso molto importanti.
Alcuni di questi possibili casi d'uso sono l'elaborazione del linguaggio naturale, l'analisi del traffico di rete e persino la rilevazione di
frodi nelle transazioni finanziarie. Gli algoritmi rilevanti in quest'area sono il quantum support vector
machine, le reti neurali quantistiche e le quantum generative adversarial networks. Ora, per chiarire, quei tre
gruppi che abbiamo appena descritto sono aree di applicazione ampie. Vale anche la pena notare che nella comunità c'è
anche un vantaggio per i gruppi che lavorano insieme e che si concentrano su un argomento specifico. IBM ha guidato un'iniziativa non molto tempo fa
chiamata Working Groups per cercare di aiutare i collaboratori a incontrarsi e creare sinergie produttive in quattro specifiche
aree: sanità e scienze della vita, materiali e HPC, fisica delle alte energie e
ottimizzazione. Ecco i nostri gruppi attuali e le entità coinvolte in quegli sforzi. Se vuoi sapere di più su
cosa stanno facendo i Working Groups, abbiamo allegato quattro dei loro white paper nella descrizione qui sotto. Ora, come ho detto,
penso che la cosa migliore da fare a questo punto del corso sia dedicare un po' di tempo a esplorare che tipo di problemi le persone stanno affrontando all'avanguardia
di questa tecnologia e sviluppare la nostra intuizione per sapere quali tipi di algoritmi funzioneranno e come
applicarli. Prima di iniziare, voglio chiarire che l'obiettivo principale qui non è capire ogni
dettaglio degli esperimenti. Questo tipo di analisi può essere molto intimidatorio anche per gli esperti se il paper è leggermente
fuori dalla tua area di competenza. L'obiettivo è semplicemente aiutare a sviluppare un'intuizione per i tipi di problemi per cui i computer quantistici
sono adatti e come gestirli. E se sei interessato ai dettagli più fini e questo ha suscitato alcune
tue idee, ti incoraggio assolutamente ad andare a leggere i paper completi. I casi d'uso specifici e
i paper che esamineremo in dettaglio sono questi. Prima, esploreremo un paper che discute
la simulazione della dinamica adronica. Questo rientra nella categoria della fisica delle alte energie. Poi, guarderemo un problema di
ottimizzazione, in particolare la biased field counter-adiabatic quantum optimization. E infine, guarderemo un altro
problema di simulazione, ma questa volta concentrandosi sull'mRNA, una molecola cruciale per
lo sviluppo di farmaci e terapie. Se hai familiarità o meno con questi paper, non è un problema. Li esamineremo tutti:
sono tre paper importanti che affrontano problemi di dimensioni sostanziali e mostrano come i computer quantistici
stiano iniziando a essere usati come un altro metodo di indagine scientifica. Primo è la simulazione della dinamica adronica
e ci immergeremo in un paper del gruppo di Martin Savage dell'Università di Washington chiamato "Quantum
simulations of hadron dynamics in the Schwinger model using 112
qubits". Se non sei un fisico delle alte energie, potresti comunque avere familiarità con il termine adrone, come nel
Large Hadron Collider o LHC, che è il gigantesco acceleratore di particelle di 27 chilometri di circonferenza che ha reso
possibile osservare finalmente il bosone di Higgs. Ora, un adrone è una particella composita subatomica composta da altre piccole
particelle chiamate quark. Alcuni esempi sarebbero neutroni e protoni. Per un po' di contesto, l'LHC è stato costruito
per consentire lo studio della fisica fondamentale e di cosa succede alle particelle quando collidono ad altissime energie
in questo tubo circolare. Facendo questo, gli scienziati sperano di saperne di più su come si è formato l'Universo primordiale
e, come ho già detto, è stato anche usato per trovare il bosone, che è una particella sfuggente responsabile della massa delle
particelle fondamentali. Ora, in linea di principio, le interazioni di queste particelle potrebbero essere
simulate dall'inizio alla fine con un computer quantistico sufficientemente potente. Non siamo ancora del tutto lì, ma si stanno facendo progressi.
Ora, il modello di Schwinger è un modello semplice usato per simulare alcune di queste dinamiche ed è emerso come uno
dei modelli di scelta più popolari. I dettagli del modello non sono super importanti per adesso, ma per i curiosi
è un modello che descrive il comportamento di elettroni e positroni che interagiscono tramite fotoni in 1+1 dimensioni,
il che significa che c'è una dimensione spaziale e il tempo. Il modello ha molte similitudini con la
cromodinamica quantistica, che descrive come quark e adroni interagiscono. Ora, quest'ultima è estremamente difficile da simulare, quindi il
modello di Schwinger è spesso usato come modello giocattolo per investigare alcuni fenomeni che sono in realtà comuni
a entrambi. Ora, il modo in cui procederemo con questo esempio e con il resto degli esempi che ho selezionato è
ponendoci una serie di domande. La prima è: perché avevamo motivo di credere che simulare questo
su un computer quantistico avrebbe funzionato? In questo caso, gli elettroni e i positroni nel modello di Schwinger hanno un effetto di schermatura
che fa sì che le correlazioni tra bosoni lontani decadano esponenzialmente con la separazione, e questo significa che non ci sono
WEBVTT
così tante interazioni a lungo raggio da un qubit su un lato del chip a un altro sull'altro lato del chip,
il che sappiamo essere molto soggetto a errori. Quindi questo è davvero positivo per l'hardware che abbiamo disponibile oggi. La prossima è:
questo argomento è anche di interesse? Beh, spero di averti già convinto che sì, la fisica delle alte energie è di grande
interesse. Le persone erano disposte a spendere miliardi di dollari per costruire l'LHC e migliaia di scienziati e
tecnici in tutto il mondo hanno dedicato la loro vita a questo campo. È così importante. Ma il modello di
Schwinger è semplicistico e non è progettato per coprire tre dimensioni spaziali. Nondimeno, è un
modello importante in quanto fornisce ancora sezioni attualmente verificabili e una semplificazione utile di una teoria
completa. Infine, come è stato fatto questo lavoro o quale approccio userebbero se stessero cercando di continuare il lavoro in
esperimenti di tipo simulazione? VQE è uno degli approcci più comuni e il primo passo è quasi sempre lo stesso:
preparare lo stato fondamentale. In questo caso è uno stato di vuoto, e in questo esperimento usano una nuova versione di VQE chiamata SC-ADAPT-VQE
per preparare sia lo stato fondamentale che il pacchetto d'onda adronico sopra il vuoto. Il passo successivo è poi
permettere agli adroni di evolvere o propagarsi nel tempo. Infine, dobbiamo identificare gli
osservabili che vogliamo rilevare. Ora, se quei passi ti suonano un po' familiari, a meno del pacchetto d'onda adronico,
è perché questi passi sono molto simili a quello che abbiamo trattato nell'esempio QAOA dell'episodio precedente.
Speriamo che tu stia iniziando a vedere emergere alcuni schemi. I componenti necessari per VQE sono molto simili a QAOA:
iniziamo in uno stato familiare, qui lo stato di vuoto, e poi lo lasciamo evolvere nel tempo con una serie di hamiltoniani
esponenziati divisi in blocchi gestibili dove n è il numero di divisioni. L'unica grande differenza qui
è che creiamo il pacchetto d'onda degli adroni centrato nel nostro circuit prima di iniziare a farlo evolvere. Quindi, come si fa?
Beh, lo stato di vuoto è lo stato fondamentale e abbiamo già più o meno trattato come mapparlo. Ora, preparare il pacchetto d'onda
adronico è un po' diverso. Su questo vuoto, un adrone può essere eccitato creando una coppia fermione-antifermione su
siti adiacenti. Preparando una sovrapposizione di tali adroni in posizioni diverse, è possibile preparare un
pacchetto d'onda arbitrario. Gli autori hanno centrato il loro pacchetto d'onda nel mezzo del circuit per osservare l'evoluzione
senza superare un confine. Ma ricorda che il nome del gioco quando si lavora con QPU rumorose è mantenere la
profondità del circuit gestibile. Per fare questo, il protocollo SC-ADAPT-VQE usa la simmetria e le
gerarchie nelle scale di lunghezza per determinare circuit quantistici a bassa profondità per la preparazione degli stati. L'idea è che questo
creerà un ansatz con un numero minore di parametri, equivalente a una profondità più ridotta. Maggiori dettagli si trovano
naturalmente nel paper più di quanto abbiamo tempo di coprire qui, quindi assicurati di consultarlo. Ora, diamo un'occhiata ai risultati. Questo esperimento è stato eseguito su
un dispositivo IBM Quantum Heron e ha implementato alcuni diversi tipi di mitigazione e soppressione degli errori,
inclusa una tecnica più recente chiamata operator decoherence renormalization, nonché dynamical decoupling, zero noise
extrapolation e Pauli twirling. Ora proviamo a interpretare i dati. L'osservabile che misureremo effettivamente
per osservare come si propaga il pacchetto d'onda è qualcosa chiamato condensato chirale, che è un po'
astratto ma è fondamentalmente una fase superfluida degli adroni. Ora possiamo vedere il pacchetto d'onda centrato qui sui
siti designati per eseguire questo esperimento, dove il colore corrisponde al condensato chirale. Il
lato sinistro mostra i risultati privi di errori dal simulatore, mentre il lato destro mostra i risultati dal computer quantistico IBM
Torino. Idealmente questi sarebbero immagini speculari l'uno dell'altro per simmetria, quindi puoi vedere che ci sono
alcune imperfezioni. Ora questo asse y verticale corrisponde ai blocchi di tempo
misurati in precedenza. Quindi perché non facciamo alcuni tagli orizzontali attraverso il primo e l'ultimo step temporale dei dati per vedere
cosa succede al pacchetto d'onda. Al tempo tau = 1, qui in arancione, corrispondente
a questo taglio, puoi vedere che il condensato chirale è stretto e localizzato. Corrisponde anche molto bene alla
simulazione eseguita per confronto. A tau = 14, però, è molto più diffuso e meno
localizzato. Forse il confronto con il simulatore non è perfetto, ma si può ancora vedere chiaramente un ottimo accordo tra teoria e dati,
il che è incoraggiante. In conclusione, questo è un esempio molto interessante del tipo di lavoro di simulazione a cui potresti non pensare inizialmente di
applicare i computer quantistici. Tuttavia, in effetti puoi farlo e funziona. Non è perfetto ma non devi essere un
esperto di fisica delle particelle per vedere che il computer quantistico prevede accuratamente la propagazione verso l'esterno del pacchetto d'onda,
che è esattamente quello che ci aspetteremmo di trovare. Speriamo che il lavoro futuro in quest'area continui e che i fisici delle alte energie
continuino a trovare modi per incorporare il quantum computing nei loro flussi di lavoro. L'obiettivo è risolvere problemi teorici in modo più preciso e
quelli che non possono essere risolti classicamente, e usare esperimenti per accettare o rifiutare teorie nella speranza di scoprire nuova
fisica, costruire rilevatori migliorati e portare a una migliore comprensione della natura al suo livello più fondamentale.
Il nostro prossimo esempio si concentra sull'ottimizzazione e sarà un'immersione profonda in un paper chiamato "biased field
digitized counter-adiabatic quantum optimization", realizzato da membri del team Kipu Quantum e dell'
Università dei Paesi Baschi in Spagna. Inizieremo come abbiamo fatto prima
con una serie di definizioni. La prima è counter-adiabatic, che è un tipo di evoluzione che sopprime gli effetti non-adiapatici
subiti da un sistema indipendentemente dalla velocità con cui si verificano quei processi. Ricorda il teorema adiabatico dal
ultimo episodio: di solito devi lasciare che un sistema evolva molto lentamente se vuoi che rimanga nello stato fondamentale.
Questo è un grosso problema perché più lentamente dobbiamo lasciar evolvere le cose, più tempo abbiamo per gli errori
verificarsi. Il counter-adiabatic driving, spesso abbreviato come CD, mira a combattere questo
aggiungendo termini che contrastano queste eccitazioni indesiderate. L'idea principale è di velocizzare l'intero esperimento e
ridurre la profondità del quantum circuit sopprimendo le eccitazioni che potrebbero portare a transizioni spurie.
Ora parliamo di cosa sia un bias field. Altri algoritmi iterativi come VQE prendono parametri classici in
questi stati e usano ottimizzatori classici per cercare nello spazio dei parametri multidimensionale il set
che produce un valore di aspettativa minimo per un hamiltoniano fisso. In questo caso, invece, variano l'hamiltoniano ogni
WEBVTT
volta, muovendosi adiapaticamente da un caso noto al caso di interesse. Ma poiché non vengono passati parametri classici
e non c'è una funzione d'onda variazionale, come aggiorni il tuo stato da un passaggio all'hamiltoniano al successivo? Beh,
aggiungono un bias field all'hamiltoniano. Qualunque sia lo stato di energia più bassa dal run precedente, aggiungono un termine nell'
hamiltoniano per far propendere lo stato verso quello. Quindi perché questo esperimento è di
interesse? Prima di tutto, questo è un nuovo approccio che potrebbe essere applicato più in generale ad altri problemi di ottimizzazione,
ma in questo caso lo hanno applicato a un problema di spin glass di Ising. Come abbiamo discusso in precedenza, molti problemi di ottimizzazione
combinatoria possono essere riformulati come ricerca di stati di bassa energia degli hamiltoniani di Ising. Il modello di
Ising è una serie di spin microscopici distribuiti su un array. Il modello può essere usato per descrivere uno spin glass in cui
la magnetizzazione è disordinata: fondamentalmente i piccoli momenti magnetici sono orientati casualmente nell'array. E
perché pensavamo che avrebbe funzionato? Beh, abbiamo già in qualche modo trattato come stiamo combattendo due tipici problemi trovati negli
algoritmi variazionali quando abbiamo trattato le definizioni del paper, ma per riassumere, l'algoritmo che stanno
proponendo accelera l'evoluzione per ridurre la profondità del circuit sopprimendo allo stesso tempo le transizioni non-adiapatiche.
Inoltre, non si basa su nessuna routine di ottimizzazione classica, il che può essere un problema che porta a
plateau sparsi e al blocco in minimi locali. Infine, gli autori si assicurano anche di allineare le interazioni nel problema
dell'hamiltoniano con la connettività dell'hardware nella QPU reale, il che è sempre molto importante. Infine, come funziona? Quindi,
come ho detto, non vengono usati ottimizzatori classici come spesso accade negli algoritmi quantistici iterativi.
Invece, alimentando la soluzione di ogni iterazione come input per la successiva, il biased field digitized
quantum optimization algorithm raffina incrementalmente lo stato fondamentale avvicinandolo sempre di più allo
stato finale evoluto. E combinato con i protocolli counter-adiabatic, possiamo farlo anche con circuit quantistici a profondità ridotta
che dovrebbero funzionare senza problemi sull'hardware rumoroso. Quindi, quando l'esperimento è stato eseguito, gli autori hanno scelto di eseguire l'
algoritmo sul computer quantistico IBM Brisbane da 127 qubit. Qui, gli autori hanno mostrato
l'ottimizzazione dell'algoritmo per un'istanza di spin glass generata casualmente con vicini più prossimi
su oltre 100 qubit. Confrontano i risultati della simulazione ideale di DCQ e BF-DCQ
nonché il risultato sperimentale, e mostrano anche un risultato da un risolutore classico chiamato Gurobi come riferimento. Ora,
con solo 10 iterazioni, BF-DCQ fornisce un miglioramento drastico rispetto a
DCQ. Sebbene il risultato sperimentale sia un po' diverso dal risultato ideale a causa del rumore, la performance è comunque
migliore del DCQ ideale. Questo mostra che ci sono ancora molti eccellenti progressi in corso per quanto riguarda
l'ottimizzazione quantistica e buoni risultati vengono riportati su oltre 100 qubit per la prima
volta. Ultimo ma non meno importante, c'è un paper molto interessante che esplora la previsione della struttura dell'mRNA dei nostri amici di
Moderna Pharmaceuticals, intitolato "mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility-scale quantum
computers". Per cominciare, se come me non hai seguito un corso di biologia da qualche anno, puoi rinfrescarti su cosa sia
l'mRNA. L'mRNA (messenger RNA) è un tipo di RNA coinvolto nella sintesi proteica.
Fondamentalmente legge le istruzioni fornite dal DNA. La struttura secondaria dell'mRNA è più o meno come la catena è piegata e
il problema di previsione della struttura secondaria dell'RNA è il problema di trovare il ripiegamento più stabile della sequenza
di basi di nucleotidi che compongono DNA e RNA, ovvero C, G, U e A. Quest'
immagine mostra alcune delle strutture di ripiegamento comuni trovate nell'mRNA. Ogni colore evidenziato qui mostra una
diversa struttura secondaria, ma le caratteristiche esatte che rendono una di queste strutture più favorevole rispetto a un'altra
non sono ben comprese. Tutto ciò che possiamo fare è capire quale ha la più bassa energia libera rispetto allo
stato non piegato, ed è qui che entrano in gioco i computer quantistici. Quindi perché le strutture secondarie dell'mRNA sono
importanti? Beh, la loro previsione accurata è in realtà cruciale non solo per comprendere il DNA e i nostri geni, ma anche
per progettare terapie basate su RNA come il vaccino contro il covid-19. C'è motivo di credere che l'approccio in
questo paper funzioni perché questo è stato a lungo noto come un formidabile problema di ottimizzazione per i computer classici
a causa del vasto numero di possibili configurazioni e per alcune configurazioni è effettivamente noto essere un
problema NP-completo. Tuttavia, su un computer quantistico, possiamo formulare la previsione della struttura secondaria come un
problema di ottimizzazione binaria, qualcosa che sappiamo come gestire. Inoltre, ci sono già prove nella letteratura
di previsione accurata dell'RNA su dispositivi quantistici su piccola scala e simulatori quantistici. Quindi la domanda ovvia è:
funzionerebbe su hardware più grande? L'esperimento viene eseguito usando qualcosa chiamato il conditional value
at risk variational quantum eigensolver, che è una modifica al tradizionale algoritmo VQE ed è
previsto per ottenere una migliore convergenza. Questo grafico mostra la distribuzione delle probabilità di misurazione
delle stringhe di bit campionati con le energie corrispondenti per un'istanza da 42
nucleotidi e 80 qubit. Qui, le stringhe di bit simboleggiano gli accoppiamenti dei
nucleotidi. Illustra che la stringa di bit a più bassa energia ha un valore di energia di -140, che corrisponde alla stringa di bit a
più bassa energia trovata dal solutore classico comparativo. Quindi è ottimo e questa è la struttura piegata ottimale
di quella catena nucleotidica basata sulla stringa di bit a più bassa energia che l'hardware ha
trovato. E con questo abbiamo raggiunto la conclusione di questo episodio. Il mio obiettivo qui non era sopraffarti con
dettagli di diversi paper di ricerca. Come ho detto, volevo semplicemente darti un contesto sufficiente per capire come appare il
lavoro all'avanguardia nel campo in questo momento. La speranza è che questo faccia girare qualche ingranaggio
nella testa di tutti e che vedendo come gli altri affrontano i problemi, potrai fare connessioni e avere la
fiducia di tentare nuovi esperimenti quantistici che potresti non aver fatto prima. E hey, forse alcuni di questi non
andranno a buon fine e va bene: è per questo che questa è ricerca. Andando avanti, ricorda che i tipi di problemi a cui siamo
interessati possono essere raggruppati per metodologia o per argomento, e abbiamo delineato quelli che riteniamo essere
WEBVTT
i più promettenti nel breve termine. Ricorda che il quantum computing non è adatto a tutto e in realtà questo è solo una
testimonianza di quanto siamo diventati bravi nel computing classico. Solo perché pensi di poter applicare il quantum computing
a un problema non significa che produrrà risultati interessanti. Purtroppo devi considerare la scala; la profondità del circuit
è un'arma a doppio taglio. Abbiamo bisogno che sia considerevolmente grande per fare lavori interessanti che i computer classici
non possono fare, ma in questo momento a causa del rumore dell'hardware non possiamo spingerla a dimensioni enormi perché la fidelità
si ridurrà. Si tratta di trovare quel punto dolce e sapere che è un obiettivo mobile. Quindi prenditi un po' di tempo
tra ora e il prossimo episodio per pensare davvero ad alcuni problemi che hai incontrato e a come potresti voler affrontarli con quello che abbiamo
imparato fino a questo punto. Sii creativo e non limitarti, e se hai delle idee anche se pensi che siano un
po' pazze, fammelo sapere nei commenti qui sotto. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.